hello welcome to another doctor Sanford
chalk and talk this time I'm going to
talk about something that may seem a
little bit abstract that actually
concerns anybody who's involved in
education as we're going to see that's a
much wider range of people than one
language one thing the topic that I'm
going to talk about is assessment of
student learning and the question that
I've been dealing with here is not one
that I've actually asked envy you or in
YouTube or emails or something like that
per se instead it's coming out of you
might say the last year of my
involvement in reaccreditation of
Fayetteville State University and
there's there's a lot of different views
on this topic including at my own
University what good is what we call
assessment of student learning why
should it be done how should it be done
what's going on and in addition to going
through reaccreditation under sands
which is one of the toughest accrediting
bodies out there currently which is
actually in some ways a good thing
because it forces you to do a lot of
things that otherwise you wouldn't do as
an institution we're also going through
some pretty hefty budget cuts but in
part because you know our state like all
the other states in the nation is
struggling with decreased revenues and
so there's some political issues about
how money is being spent we're pumping
in
education and the budget revenues
preparations issue the assessment issue
I'm going to argue here or actually
intimately connected and they really
want that's another thing that I do
anything so here's the way of framing a
question why it's really to question why
and how should colleges and universities
carry out assessments tumor obviously
I'm not going to go very deep into this
because you can you know find entire
libraries full of how to do assessments
you're learning i'm just going to talk
with a very basics of it but i'm going
to be really concerned that the y hush
but in order to answer why you also have
to understand some of the hot so when
we're talking about assessment of
student wondering what are we talking
assessment takes place with a lot of
different ways through a lot of
different tools and had a lot of
different levels and also for a lot of
different motors so let's slowly look at
a few of those let's think about levels
you can assess your students in your
class every time you could test to
pretend that you won't work assignment
you are assessing their knowledge or
their skills or perhaps even develop
dispositions you might need to get just
given great you might be doing that in
order to help them improve their skills
that may be part of the process you
might be
diagnostic way these are all different
possibilities you can have you can leave
these assessments together into matrix
or entire course and you can do this
going up a level so you do this going
from the class to the programs in the
philosophy program to or the department
all the way out to the College in this
case college of arts and sciences you
can do it all the way up to the
University academic affairs you might
assess certain skills for instance those
that are talking philosophy 110-year
critical thinking a required course
critical thinking is one of those sets
of skills and dispositions as well as
some content knowledge that really has
to be diffused throughout the entire
curriculum as a matter of fact unless
you have some modicum of those skills
develop you can't really do much of
anything can just like your
communication skills great if you have
you know wonderful ideas but you can't
communicate them effectively you have to
develop those skills and you're out
Nicole there are some other sets of
skills like that as well call
fundamental skills you can assess the
entire university or you can assess
cohorts this year's freshman compared to
this year's juniors is yours freshman
compared to where they are two years you
know those are all the composing
assessment what are you actually
assessment well there are different ways
of framing this I like to think of it
knowledge what is it that you actually
know what came to reproduce the
fundamental building blocks that you
have to have in order to make things
work for instance if you want to talk
about critical thinking you have to have
the concept of argument and you have to
actually understand it that's not even
at the level of skill that's just you
know some knowledge then skills are what
you can actually do with them can you
analyze mark that's actually not just a
seal the whole set interwoven skills and
then dispositions critical thinking
again includes a number of different
dispositions as well as skills
disposition is being something that's
actually woven into your character or
the fabric of your personality being
education if it's actually doing its job
should not just be imparting information
not just teaching people how to do
things but also you know helping them to
modify who they are so that they realize
their full potential that's that's what
the local dispositions now you can ask
where students currently are you can
take a snapshot of their skills or their
dispositions of their knowledge at any
given point you can also buy by
assessing them at different points try
to figure out whether they're improving
whether they're actually declining
sometimes your assessments by showing
that despite your efforts or perhaps
because of some things you do students
may actually get worse in some things
assessment can also indicate you with
problem areas that you need to dress how
do you do it well there's there's a lot
of different ways to assess and again
I'm going to generalize very very
liberally here I understand through
way to do it this what I'm saying here
but it really comes down to do you
assess performance or a tss of proxy are
you with approximately you're
substituting something else in place of
say the skills that you want the
students to demonstrate so again let's
take critical thinking for an example if
you want to know whether students can
actually diagnose fallacious arguments
in real life arguments and you give them
a multiple choice test which is rather
artificial in a body says this is he
committing the fallacy of that comment
on appeal to pity that's y pensar etc
that's a proxy if you require them to
actually do tasks that require the use
of those skills in situations that are
fairly like that or if you in fact ask
them to tell you what somebody in such a
situation would be able to do then your
assessment performance in an authentic
way I mean proxy there is performance
involved in that right but it's a
performance that's being substituted for
really authentically looking at those
skills and this is why multiple choice
tests you know I'm not knocking unfort
early they are read sometimes processing
content knowledge but they're going to
often they're not going to be good at it
again skills and dispositions so ideally
you want to be assessing not just by
proxies but assessor performance now
quite often when people get involved
with assess
there's there's two extremes that they
go to and both of these are actually
problematic one extreme that I never was
at myself we've never tempted by but I
understand the temptations of is to try
to quantify them yeah that ends up in
negatively introducing a lot of proxies
a lot of the end of grade tests that we
see are those type of assessments and
you can teach to the test and that's one
of the dangers that happens but when
you're teaching to the test you're
actually teaching more just content and
not actually skills you're not helping
the students to develop the skills lo
the dispositions of me now why do people
assess it well it's easy to do them and
it's easy to crunch those numbers and
you can turn out and say you know the
this who all got 68% this flow got any a
person this will 168 to a seventy eight
percent it's very unclear what you're
actually assessing their weather whether
it connects with what education is
supposed to be imparting to your
students now if that is the model of
assessment then you get the other
extreme and I was it that other extreme
myself you get a lot of people in the
arts in the humanities and even some in
the Natural Sciences because they're the
ones they're fine with assessing things
mathematically statistically in terms of
physical things but not when it comes to
psychological and social scientists tend
to love you know the numbers based
assessments sometimes you get people
humanities you miss
major of assessment and they think that
it only includes proxy assessment and so
their view is that why should we do this
sort of thing it's a waste of time we're
imposing foolish things on her students
were actually teaching them the wrong
thing not only are we are emphasizing
too much of the content knowledge and
not enough of the actual skills that
integrate that content knowledge but we
are actually teaching them that
education is just about learning units
of information which that they
regurgitate now if that was indeed the
case and that is indeed the case in some
you know some regimes of assessment
that's a bad thing you don't actually
want although that's better than doing
no no assessment at all footprint that's
better than just that will be all just
kind of feel like we're learning I mean
I would rather actually get an end of
grade multiple choice test students then
did not do anything but there are a lot
better ways of doing things assessment
includes performance and you can do this
by using rubrics and there's a lot of
great information out there there's a
lot of workshops out there on how to
create not just quantitative but
qualitative Reuters for all of the type
of skills that you would want to assess
all given dispositions with our rubrics
out there for development of ethical
knowledge application of ethical knology
integration of it's the change in one's
life demonstrating the ability to to
process these things at higher levels
but a lot of different ways in which we
can steer students or it's making these
qualitative leads step by step
and it doesn't necessarily have to
include proxies again I'm not knocking
proxy test there is a legitimate place
but it can't be the whole now those
people who you know in the humanities
think that's the whole of it or in arts
or even some of the national science
because they think that it's going to be
exactly like what they're dealing with
visit I don't want that apply to
psychological traits about about people
if you think that that's all there is to
it it's understandable why you would be
against assessment I was in that key
what changed my mind was being
introduced to a very powerful tool for
assessment of critical thinking
communication problem solving skills
call the CLA I'm not going to talk about
that here that can be the subject of
another nunchaku target different time
what it showed me was that it was
possible to assess student performance
in those skills and dispositions very
meaningful ways that allow me as an
educator to say yeah I'm actually
assessing I'm actually checking what
they do know of what they can do with
that knowledge and I'm doing it in a way
that's not really our official that's
not just make work that baggage I can
actually demonstrate growth in my
students if I am doing my job well
here's where we get to the other one
what assessment allows you to do is
allow you to show to your stakeholders
that you are actually doing your job
there's there's a lot of educators who I
think have gotten into the mentality
that just give me the students and I'll
teach up and get the hell out of my way
well that's not good
we are under what's been called the
regime not only of assessment but of
accountability especially as the budgets
of the getting cut especially as
programs have to justify themselves
philosophy is one of the key ones
actually it has to come up with some
sort of justification for why it exists
and I am NOT an awesome pathetic and I'm
in the story in a philosophy so I love
the history of philosophy for its own
sake but i have not about sympathetic to
to those who say well we should just get
to teach whatever we want and whatever
the students take from it good for them
but our subjects are so valuable that we
get to do whatever we like with the
taxpayer dollars I don't think that's
responsible at all and I think it's
actually quite selfish if you actually
are going to claim that studying
philosophy benefits and it can be shown
you have to show same thing with English
same thing with natural sciences
anything with the social sciences one he
has to demonstrate one he has to talk to
I think three kinds of stakeholders who
are you being a cutesy here who are you
and who does the University responsible
too and there's really three kinds of
stakeholders I'm going to call these the
bank rollers the contributors and the
integrators and what I mean by this the
bank rollers is pretty pretty
intuitively obvious who's paying for who
does pay for education well even if it's
at a private university in large part
it's a gum state-federal a lot of money
is being spent to contribute
also you know other stakeholders like
Rangers those who are putting money into
these these these institutions of higher
learning when we talk about the
compromise where is the government
getting its money on the taxpayers the
taxpayers especially for talking about
state institution the taxpayers have a
right to be shut to have demonstrated to
them in some de menthe in some tangible
way that when they pump all this money
into education it's not just going down
into a sinkhole that something is
actually taking place that improvements
are taking place that there are
thoughtful improvements that you can not
necessarily measure every single aspect
but you can measure some of it that you
can provide some sort of justification
for what you're doing the days of lack
of accountability I think are over we're
are the contributors oh there's another
parents and of course who goes through
the entire thing students lot of
students are financing their own
education they actually I believe have a
right to have demonstrated to them that
we are actually doing something for them
we are actually making them not
necessarily forcing them to become
better educated but we are creating all
of the opportunities we are observing
ourselves what they are doing this is
some sort of concerted thoughtful way to
make sure that you know whatever level
they're at I all my teaching has been
low to your under funded institutions
whatever level you're at you can be
working to improve student learn to
improve to improve the opportunities
that they have to to you know flesh out
the curriculum to get rid of the things
that don't work I think that students
really have a right to that information
from from the universities from the
faculty that suits you who are the
contributors
who actually provides the the
environment in which learning takes
place will faculty or at the absolute
center faculty are stapled it sounds
like everything is being put on faculty
but faculty also have a right to the
main up I think in any good institution
the faculty in one area wat to be able
to demand especially when it comes to
poor education what are you people doing
over there show us that what you're
doing is actually working Ross well of
course administrator and I think the
board of trustees or whoever else is in
charge they are involved with them I
think students are also part of the
contributors and if you have something
going on like service learning or
internships I would also say the larger
outside community but I'm just put them
over here under integrators because who
actually has to take in these students
who come out of our institutions it's
the outside communities that they go
back to if all of your students are you
know local students then your community
should be caring whether education is
really taking place otherwise you're
just keeping kids off the streets unless
you can actually demonstrate
tangible way that these kids are coming
up better than they came when they when
they entered four years or five years or
six years later the community should you
know have a beef with you or not if
you're not actually demonstrating that
you're producing better educated
citizens people that can hold good jobs
that can contribute to their community
you're failing is an institution and I
think there are a lot of institutions
that are there doing that because
they're not thinking about this and not
grasp it's not that the institution is
actually bad they're not getting this
well employers we should be asking
employers and the better institutions
are doing this what do you want from our
graduates are we actually giving you in
our graduates what you in fact need for
the workplace for today's workplace you
know what are the things that actually
top those less critical thinking skills
communication skills some sort of
ethical set of values and the work ethic
are we getting coal kidding you don't
work out by the way that's not Islanders
you know that's disposition are we
inculcate if we're not but if we can't
show that we're doing that then they
want to say why should we
take your graduates why should we
bankroll why should employers these are
the bank robbers why should they be
interested why should employers be here
as part of contributors taking in
students as interns if the interns are
not going to do good work or they're not
prepared we have to demonstrate that
we're doing a lot better than we have
overall now I'm not saying that every
institution is on the same level of that
in this respect or that every
institution has to do as much work I
think that some institutions have been
very very good and can actually be
models in showing how assessment can be
thoughtfully woven into the process of
continual improvement generating more
and more student learning especially in
these difficult circumstances there is
one other thing I'd like to say about
assessment if you're going to try to
assess the institution as a whole we are
doing that here with critical thinking
at a fitness timmers critical thinking
problem solving and written
communication if you're going to try to
do something like that which I think
that you want to do not only for
Prudential reasons but also to go to
ethical duty to do you have to be able
to address these stakeholders where they
are it's one thing to be able to present
complicated assessment data to granting
agencies like the Incarnate language
they understand you also have to be able
to provide information
to taxpayers and parents and businesses
and the people in the outside community
in terms that they can understand this
generates some real challenges because
the finer the instruments that you're
using for assessment the more
complicated it gets right and these more
simple the instruments well the more
simple the output that you're giving
them in nice graphs or whatever however
you like to present it you're losing
some of the salty and some of the
process by my doings or aren't you so it
takes some it's real thinking about how
to do this well it may be that you want
to have several different ways to
present the same assessment data to
present the same processes again I'm
going to put in a plug here for the CLA
the collegiate learning assessment
performance test methodology only in
part because I think that it actually
provides you with something that on an
institutional scale if you're doing a
longitudinal studies that's very
complicated statistical sampling and a
number crunching and you know that's not
going to be helpful to show stage
appearance or two to taxpayers but you
can actually generate by my use of other
ways in which you look at the seal that
Dad that's what we have done here as you
rise to your refreshment you can show
using that rubric how our students
developed where are they right now how
have they developed you're entering
freshmen to rising juniors how are they
going to go from rising juniors
to exit and seniors you can also use it
and i have used it in my classrooms to
get students feedback on their critical
thinking abilities and what they need to
do to improve that's an example of a
good assessment there's a lot of good
assessments out there and I believe that
there are a lot of good assessments
waiting to be born out of the mines not
not quite you know fully formed like
thena popping of the miners oops but
waiting to be born of the minds of those
who are applying themselves to these
problems but I think so to recap I think
that we have an ethical dude to be
explaining ourselves to these
stakeholders which which include us that
but also include all these other people
so that's why I think universities and
colleges should be carrying our
assessment student learning I haven't
wandered the how very far into how can't
do that in the short time but I think
that I was hopefully I went put the case
before you why it is that we should be
assessing student learning why we should
publicizing it why we should be thinking
about how we're going to present this to
these stakeholders and I think that to
be very thoughtful also what means of
assessment we use I'm not gonna leave
you with an any question this one
because I think I've already posed a
number of different questions and people
maybe someone confused watching this if
they're not specialists in education but
if you have any questions about this or
you want to say I've got it right or say
that I'm totally wrong on this or the
assessment isn't something we want to be
doing more you don't have to just
congress also them email me or put a
comment on